[Music]
john is in milwaukee hey john welcome to
the ramsey show
hey uh it's so good to be here i'm a
longtime listener first time caller
thanks for taking my call absolutely how
can we help
oh yeah this is a question really for
ken um so for the past year i've been
working as a freelance photographer
i really thought i was clear about what
i wanted to do but i'm i'm really having
some doubts here
what are you doubting specifically
um so i i work in freelance as a real
estate photographer
and so the past of maybe six months have
been really challenging because
um essentially
the uh the market of course is so hot
and crazy and uh it you know you could
sell a house in your sleep essentially
and uh so i've really been struggling to
kind of make it happen and i think just
really dealing with like imposter
syndrome as well just like man there's
there's so many other photographers in
the area and things like that um and i
really thought i was clear so when you
say you're struggling to make it happen
meaning uh because houses are moving so
quickly people don't need photographers
and your work is dried up is that what
i'm hearing
correct yeah well so let's just remove
that for a second and i know that's hard
but suspend some reality for just a
moment if you were rocking and rolling
right now as i'm assuming at least
you've been much busier than you are now
would you be calling me with doubt and
imposter syndrome
uh probably not no so what we have to
look at is it is your circumstances
it is your
current season
that is causing all of the doubt and by
the way that's very natural so give
yourself a break there's nothing wrong
with you
you shouldn't feel bad about it but
you're just facing some good old tough
times and when times get tough we start
to doubt ourselves because we start
looking at all of the other things
instead of the reality which is because
of these circumstances in this market
you're having a tougher time but the
reality is is when you got into
photography and picked up a camera for
the first time you wanted to take
pictures and you haven't lost that juice
for being artistic and creative in that
way true or false
uh true okay so great so what we do is
we say is it always going to be this way
are these uh real estate circumstances
in this current market are they always
going to be this way yes or no
no no
are you still creative whether or not
you're shooting real estate pictures or
not
yes or no oh yeah of course yeah so uh
photographers have to hustle you got to
get out there so
my overall advice to you is
understand that what you're experiencing
right now is good old-fashioned
uh tough times that create doubt get
clear and i just helped you kind of
re-establish for a moment what you
believe about photography and what you
love to do and why you love to do it so
start taking pictures of everything else
there's a lot of things you can take
pictures of if you've got to go work a
side hustle for a season just to stay in
the game then that's what you do but do
not quit this you will regret it if you
walk away from being a photographer i
got lost in your story arc just a second
ago um
did you ever make a living doing this
uh no it's a side hustle that i i
decided to make full-time uh last year
at exactly the wrong time okay yeah so
yeah yeah i mean not your fault but
that's just the way it worked out thank
you to pandemics and so forth the um
um so when you were in the side hustle
what kind of money were you making
um
it was less than 20 000
uh and what have you made now that it's
full time and times are tough
uh
even less than that yeah i'd say yeah
all right yeah so it's still a side
hustle but we don't quit i mean we do so
you got one or two options you can
backfill
the hard times
with a uh and make it a side hustle
again with a new with a new gig that's a
temporary gig it's gonna be two years
three years you're gonna work a job
while you build this thing back up you
get back get your feet back under you
because you got the wind knocked out of
you um
because you jumped at exactly the wrong
time like they moved the freaking boat
right as you jumped you know i mean
somebody hit the gas on it and you know
that kind of thing but your fault but
it's like a bad trick you know a cosmic
jokester so uh the the other option is
that you can look at it your business
model and go okay real estate is
and i hey i got my real estate license
in 1978
john
this is the weirdest market i have ever
seen
i'm telling you i mean it's a weird it's
got so many components to it elements to
it that are just
strange
so you know is it going to last that way
absolutely not it's just an anomaly
and so
it's not status quo it's not predictable
into the future it's not that kind of
stuff so having said that you either you
either backfill with a full-time gig
like you used to do
and go get a similar job like you used
to have just as a you know and say i'm
gonna do this for two three years get my
feet back under me let this market
stabilize and then re-enter or you pivot
with the photography and go i'm going to
take pictures of stuff other than houses
and try to add some things to your
product line
that is happening right now
kids sports
i had a friend that made a bazillion
dollars taking little league
sport pictures it's the easiest sale in
the history of the world sport pictures
hey parents you want a picture with your
kid and
the only problem you got is there's
other people doing it but i mean it's
just yes
it is i mean and action photos
of of a six-year-old playing soccer i
mean it's amazing so
i don't know i'm just making stuff up
here but that camera can point at things
other than just houses yeah you got to
diversify but the big thing is is you
don't quit you know it's like he called
and said i thought i was going no you
didn't you didn't know you were clear
you absolutely still you just had you
you know just like some of the stuff i
launched last year uh my timing sucked
your timing sucks okay i got some stuff
that i just assumed last year hadn't
occurred uh i'm trying to forget it as
dr john deloney would say i'm recovering
i'm recovering from trauma